nuevas soluciones por parte de los
cancilleres europeos esta vez contra la
compañía de mercenarios rusa wagner por
graves violaciones de los derechos
humanos también se han ampliado a
sanciones contra ocho individuos y tres
entidades relacionadas de alguna forma
con esta compañía que ha participado en
multitud de conflictos desde ucrania
pasando por libia o también república
centroafricana además preocupa
especialmente las relaciones recientes
que ha mantenido esta compañía privada
con el gobierno de malí para ofrecer
servicios de seguridad y protección a
partir de ahora se van a congelar los
activos además se va a impedir que
individuos relacionados con esta
compañía podrá entrar en territorio
europeo esta compañía preocupa muy
especialmente a europa por la violación
y la desestabilización que puede
provocar en el territorio europeo además
preocupa muy especialmente sus
relaciones con el kremlin y también
especialmente porque podría recibir
protección por parte del gobierno de
vladimir putin estas son de momento en
las únicas sanciones que se han aprobado
con relación a rusia aunque los
cancilleres europeos aseguran que están
muy pendientes de una posible agresión a
ucrania por parte de moscú